the basilisk is a creature that we've
seen appear in many beasty areas and
works of fantasy but how many of you
have heard of the cockatrice a creature
that was once often confused with the
basilisk because of its many
similarities the fastest way to
distinguish between the two is through
their physical appearance there are
depictions of the cockatrice where it
appears as a dragon with the head of a
cockerel but it's much more common to
see the cockatrice in the form of a bird
in recent depictions the basilisk
appears as a large serpent like creature
with older images showing it to be an
eight-legged reptilian monster if you
were wondering how the two creatures
were born well this is the part where it
gets a little bit weird and confusing
the cockatrice is hatched from the egg
of a cockerel that's been incubated by a
snake and the basilisk is hatched by the
egg of a snake that's been incubated by
a cockerel I know weird the cockatrice
is considered to be a type of Chimera
and in 14th century medieval England the
cockatrice appeared as a bird-like
reptile who was able to turn people into
stone with its gaze much like the
Chimera the cockatrice was able to
breathe fire and take flight in its
earliest appearances the cockatrice was
believed to be no bigger than a few
inches so essentially you had a
fire-breathing chicken that could fit in
the palm of your hand not exactly the
most terrifying creature but its size
did increase in later depictions
there are several ways to kill a
cockatrice if it was to see its own
reflection in a mirror it's likely that
it will turn itself into stone
according to legend the cockatrice would
immediately die upon hearing the crow of
a rooster the only animal that was
believed to be immune to the glance of
the cockatrice was the weasel despite
sharing its appearance of a serpent the
movement of the basilisk was unlike any
other snake
it does not slither with its belly on
the ground it crawls forward with the
front of its body towering above the
earth
unlike the cockatrice which was known to
be a rather small creature serpent like
basilisks are known to grow to gigantic
proportions similar to the cockatrice
the gaze of the basilisk is believed to
be able to turn anyone into stone
the breath of a basilisk is believed to
be so putrid that it can wither plants
and even incapacitate grown men there
are some tales where the basilisk is
able to breathe fire but these tales are
few and far the venom of a basilisk is
so toxic that it can kill a person from
meters away without making any contact
the two creatures do share many of the
same weaknesses those who were
attempting to slay a basilisk would
often throw a weasel or a rooster into
the beasts den
hoping that the sound of the roosters
crow would turn the monster into ashes
there is no doubt that the basilisk in a
cockatrice are very similar creatures
the basilisk has become a staple in
works of fantasy whereas the cockatrice
has been relegated to nothing more than
a medieval legend it's not hard to
imagine why there's been this evolution
from the cockatrice to the basilisk in
modern depictions it's a lot harder to
install fear into an audience if the
creature attempted to kill them
resembles a barnyard animal I mean how
good would the chamber of secrets really
been if Harry was being chased through
Hogwarts by a tiny fire-breathing
chicken it would have been hilarious
but hopefully you understand the point
I'm trying to make i feel the basilisk
presents a more sinister and terrifying
figure
if you've enjoyed this video then please
consider leaving a thumbs up as it helps
promote the video and allows the channel
to grow if there's anything you'd like
to discuss or have any ideas for future
videos then please let me know in the
comment section as always I've been your
host mythology and fiction explained